the man accused of killing four
University of Idaho students could face
trial as soon as October yesterday a
judge said try that trial date for Brian
coburger at a court hearing where the
accused stood silent the sister and
father of one of the victims Kaylee
Gonzalez attended that hearing and spoke
with our Lilia Luciano
this individual is it's small it's
scared it's frail Olivia Gonzalez says
Monday was the first time she was in the
same room as the man accused of killing
her sister Kaylee she told us she was
anxious going in but was surprised to
see him as barely human there wasn't
much that I felt that I had to fear
there it felt very weak the accused
looked Straight Ahead as the judge read
the four murder charges against him
stating he could face the death penalty
for each one do you understand the
maximum yes
standing silent has the same legal
effect as entering a not guilty plea CBS
News legal contributor Jessica Levinson
says standing silent could give the
defendant more options amid any possible
plea negotiations he keeps on the table
the possibility that he could plead
guilty in exchange for not receiving the
death penalty Keeley Gonzalez's father
Steve was in the courtroom as well how
did you feel about what happened today
in court
it was a little
unusual for me to know that you could
go on you know not make a plea but it's
not easy it's not easy to look at
somebody and know that there's a very
likely possibility that they're
responsible of doing these type of
behaviors
for CBS mornings I'm Lilia Luciano in
Moscow Idaho